is it worth buying the new Apple watch
series 9 or should you just get a series
8 for up to 230 dollars off instead and
with that maybe you should get an Apple
Watch se2 for way less money well today
I will explain and show you guys all of
the differences and I think some of you
guys are gonna be really surprised by my
conclusion now I have used and purchased
a ton of apple watches in the past
there's always some nuances that you
can't just tell based on spec so this is
the new series nine and last year with
the series eight there were very little
differences but Apple has really
impressed us this year now the color on
this one is midnight just like with my
series 8 but Apple announced a new pink
color this year which I thought would be
really cool for my daughter that's
something you can't get on the series 8
so that is a nice bonus and you get a
lot of color options with the series
nine especially compared to the SE where
you have midnight Starlight and silver
and now that I have him laying down
right here it is hard to tell which one
of these is the new series 9 because
they are identical if you look at the
sensors the whole design and of course
the se you guys see that it has that
vinyl back which is basically plastic
Apple actually wanted to make it cheaper
it also makes it a little bit lighter
even if you get the larger size and we
have the smallest size of the se2
compared to the 45 millimeter on the
series eight and nine so you guys could
see that size difference now we also
have a second generation Optical sensor
here on the se2 compared to the newer
ones that are a little bit faster and
more accurate now of course with that
you have a much smaller price tag and
what is really nice is that not only
does it start at 249 dollars compared to
400 on the series nine but if you want
LTE that only costs you fifty dollars
inside of 1 hundred and that is great if
you're on a budget or if you want to buy
an Apple Watch for your kids which is
what I have done with this se2 I got
cellular connectivity and they don't
even need an iPhone to be able to have
texting and for me to be able to track
where they're at so that is very nice
now with the series 9 if you want a
larger size and you want cellular well
you're looking at 530 dollars and with
that you can also switch to stainless
steel and then your price tag goes way
up and then if you want a nicer band
you're looking at 800 bucks which is
absolutely insane and the crazy thing is
Apple is no longer offering their
leather bands anymore they switch to the
new fine woven which is still crazy
expensive but nowhere near as nice but
thankfully our sponsor band work in
Germany makes some of the highest
quality genuine leather bands including
their brand new bandwork X collection
with their new performance leather
straps with this awesome two-tone design
in various finishes like their class see
black and brown leather band using
premium German Heinen leather renowned
for its waterproof qualities so check it
out and order one today by using the
link below and the code Max Tech 23 so
you can add a one ounce Leather Cream to
your cart for free alongside your
premium band from bandwork now I'm going
to move the se2 aside I'm going to start
this comparison with the 8 and the 9
because we have a lot of differences
this year then we'll touch on the se2
now on the outside these look identical
and inside they are almost identical as
well apart from a few chips now on the
display one thing you guys might notice
right now is that the series 9 looks
brighter now we are indoors but if we
were Outdoors you would see a big
difference because the series 9 can go
up to 2 000 nits which is what the ultra
had last year compared to a thousand and
that makes a big difference in the
sunlight with that it can get a lot
dimmer as well down to one knit which is
nice in dark environments so you might
not even have to use the theater mode
anymore now one of the new hardware
changes is the new YouTube Ultra wide
band chip and that will allow you to
easily find your phone instead of just
pinging it and making a sound it will
actually guide you to your phone which
is really really convenient it will also
give you interactions with your home pod
like passing through audio but what I
was more excited for is the new S9 sip
the Apple Watch series 8 uses the S8 but
that chip is basically the same as the
series 7 and Series 6 Apple watch where
the new S9 is using a 5 nanometer
technology and that has some huge
improvements finally it has 5.6 billion
transistors and the CPU is up to 60
faster Graphics up to 30 faster and
while most people won't complain about
the performance of their apple watches
what that actually does matters much
more comparing it to the series 8 Apple
watch and even the se2 which uses the
same chip dictation is faster and more
accurate and doing serial requests it's
all on the device now it doesn't have to
go in the cloud so that is really nice
because sometimes you might ask for a
stopwatch or something else my kids use
this feature all the time and the Apple
watch will say well it doesn't have a
good connection right now or I can't do
this right now all those things can now
be done on your Apple watch no matter
where you are at so that is awesome but
what is even more exciting is is the new
double tap feature that Apple showed off
now that doesn't arrive till next month
with the software update but it will
allow you to control your Apple watch by
just tapping your fingers so you can end
a call you can do a lot of different
things with this even if your hands are
busy or they're dirty instead of having
to lift it up and use your nose to touch
the screen which I've done a lot of
times so this is going to be really
handy but personally what I was most
excited about is the battery life
Improvement now Apple quoted the same 18
hours and if you go on their website
that's what they show you but my son has
been using this series 9 and the
improvements have been huge he went from
a SE which wouldn't even last all day
because it uses cellular and that uses
more power to the series 9 which at the
end of the day it's still close to half
of the battery remaining and that's
thanks to the new more efficient S9 chip
now a lot of people have been talking
about the real world experiences online
one person said he is getting two days
out of his series nine on another person
said they got 14 hours including a 45
minute workout from their watch it was
still at 62 percent battery and another
person said they had 52 percent at the
end of the day and this is incredible
real world difference is that apple does
not mention because they just want to
quote the same exact battery life so
this matters not only when you're buying
a new Apple watch but two three four
years later when the battery started to
degrade your battery will last much
longer if you have the series 9
especially if you use cellular because
of that I would say that the series 9
even though a lot of the other Hardware
is the same this is one of the biggest
updates that we have had in many years
now other than those changes everything
else is practically the same so what
kind of difference do you get if you are
looking to buy an se2 compared to the
series 9 is it worth the extra cost now
the first thing that you'll notice is of
course the size difference but you can
get this in a large larger size and with
that the display on the series 9 is much
brighter thanks to that upgrade the
series 9 also has an always-on display
which is now quite bright compared to
previous versions whereas the se2 does
not have that so you have to use race to
wake you also have a lot of additional
sensors for example you have a blood
oxygen sensor which could be really
useful especially for my son who has
allergies and with that you can you do
an ECG to check on your heart and you
also have a temperature sensor on the
series 9 which they use for ovulation
tracking and those things can be a big
deal for some people now with that even
though both of these are LTE and they
connect to Wi-Fi having that new Chip is
going to give you better connectivity
and even though Apple doesn't advertise
it what we've noticed in the real world
that even for cellular you will have
better reception with the newer models
not going to be helpful all also
downloading and installing apps setting
it up much quicker on the new one and
the internal storage has also been
updated you have 64 gigs on the new
series 9 compared to all the previous
Apple watches for local storage now both
of these can be used for sleeve tracking
but I would say on the se2 it's a lot
less useful because of the battery life
and the charging speed the series 9 has
fast charging where it can go up to 80
percent in just 45 minutes so if you're
sleeping with it you can just put it on
your charger when you wake up as you're
getting ready and it charges incredibly
fast and even my son has noticed that in
the real world so if you care about
using a lot of Those sensors for working
out and for other things the series 9 is
much more useful in the real world now
durability is fairly similar but the
series 9 has ip6x dust resistance so
that is a little bit improved and
another thing to know about the display
even though apple on unlocked a bunch of
Apple watches with software updates with
the series 9 and the 8 you actually have
an exclusive watch face where kind of
Curves around the edge because the whole
display actually curves making your
viewing area larger than on the SE even
if you get the larger size model now one
super cool exclusive that the SE doesn't
get is full keyboard support So as you
guys could see with the se you still
have to do the old school one letter at
a time or use your voice whereas with
the series 9 you have a full keyboard
where you can actually type and my kid
loves this update and then if you do
choose to use your voice it's a lot more
accurate as well so with all that
covered let's answer the original
question should you buy a series 9 or
should you get a series 8 or an se2 well
this year my answer is going to be a lot
different than last year if you're
trying to buy an Apple Watch that's a
very inexpensive one you're trying to
get into it last year we recommended the
se2 this year though I would not I would
go on Amazon and pick up a series 8
instead because the refurbished prices
even with cellular pretty much match up
with buying a new se2 with cellular the
prices are crazy and you get most of the
updates with the series nine on the
series eight so that is incredible but
if you had an older Apple watch already
you have a little bit more money to
spend this year I would say absolutely
get the series 9. the display
Improvement is nice the ultra wide band
chip is nice but the most important part
is having that new S9 chip which is the
new chip in about four years and that
will give you much better battery life
it's going to make your Apple watch last
much longer than previously and that is
what really matters so I would spend the
extra money on the S9 if there is any
way that you can afford to get one I
think that is the smart choice and that
is why I spent and 529 dollars for this
one instead of buying my son a series 8
refurbished one because it makes that
much of a difference especially after a
couple of years you guys let me know
what you end up buying down below check
out band work their bands are amazing
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there at the spin Max and I'll see you
in the next one foreign
[Music]